Let's go back to our list of concepts, go back to our diagram of where we were
and say, "What should be the next step?" Well, what can we do now?
We can take a hand and we can take a single letter on the board and we can say,
"Yes, I can pick letters out of the hand and maybe do a S-I-D-E."
That would be a good play, except if there was an X here, then it would not be a good play.
Similarly, if there were letters in the opposite direction, that could be a bad play.
But sometimes, there's letters in the opposite direction and it makes a good play.
Where here I'm forming two words at once, and the rules are the play I have to make
has to be all in one direction and all adjacent to each other so forming one consecutive word.
Then if it incidentally forms some other words in the other directions, that's okay.
But I can't put some in this direction and then put some others down in that direction.
I think my next goal will be to place words on a row
while worrying about the crosswords in the opposite direction.